bonsoir en raison de la grève du
personnel d'un tel que nous appliquons
aujourd'hui le programme minimum prévu
c'est ainsi que notre programme de ce
soir se composera d'un film que vous
verrez dans quelques instants et d'une
émission de jazz ce filou ses quatre
balles ou un film américain d'elliot
silverstein avec jane fonda lee marvin
dans les rôles principaux
ainsi que le regretté nat king cole que
vous verrez tout au long du fil ou
chanter la balade de cad bane nous il
s'agit d'un western nettement ou
parodiques dont les personnages sont
très pittoresque particulièrement celui
qui interprète l'hymne arfi et puis aux
alentours de 22 heures un petit peu
avant de 22 heures un spécial benny
carter émission de jean christophe
averty consacré au saxophoniste
clarinettiste et trompettiste ainsi que
chef d'orchestre benny carter il n'y
aura pas de dernier journal ce soir en
raison de la grève bien sûr c'est donc
après cette émission de jazz que se
terminera notre programme mais tout de
suite je vous laisse faire la
connaissance étaient quatre
bonne soirée